ähnlich positiv mit arbeitslos das war
nur ein kleines rotes
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zur pressekonferenz
mit verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner und universitäts professor dr
wolff & müller und ich darf die
verteidigungsministerin ersuchen zu
beginnen
vielen dank sehr geehrter
universitäts-professor sehr geehrte
damen und herren das eres geschichtliche
museum ist speziell
es ist deshalb speziell weil es das
einzige militärhistorische museum in
österreich ist und es ist ein sehr
erfolgreiches museum weil durchaus auch
die besucherzahlen in den letzten jahren
stark gestiegen sind und dennoch hat
mich die thematik der zustände im
heeresgeschichtlichen museum seit beginn
meiner amtszeit begleitet denn in den
vergangenen jahren sind ohne zweifel
versäumnisse passiert es haben sich
mandy und problemfelder aufgetan die
teilweise bis zum jahr 955 zurückgehen
aber ich beziehungsweise wir sind fest
entschlossen dieses problem zu lösen und
zwar nachhaltig zu lösen
in der zwischenzeit hat sich einiges
getan
wir haben zum einen durch den
rechnungshofbericht und durch die
bereits präsentierten berichte der
beiden kommissionen unter der leitung
von professor mockridge einen besseren
überblick zum einen über die diversen
herausforderungen probleme im bereich
der verwaltung und zum anderen dem
eigentlichen musik ein bereich bekommen
und darüber hinaus haben wir im november
des vorjahres
eine evaluierung des gesamten angebotes
im museumsshop das war gm anberaumt
nachdem vorwürfe insbesondere in den
medien nach laut wurden dass sich
angeblich rechtsextreme literatur und
waren darunter befinden würden
wir haben daher eine kommission mit
fachexperten und expertinnen aus dem
universitären bereich eingeladen die
dieses warenangebot genau prüfen und
evaluieren sollten ja unter bericht
dieser evaluierungskommission unter der
leitung von herrn universitäts professor
dr wolfgang müller ist nun fertig
geworden und wir dürfen daher der
öffentlichkeit präsentieren
an dieser stelle ist es mir ein
bedürfnis mich auch gleich bei ihnen
sehr geehrter herr professor zu bedanken
und selbstverständlich auch den anderen
kommissionsmitgliedern für die
umfangreiche monatelange arbeit dem
besonders sorgfältiger art und weise
passiert ist diese kommission hat sich
ganz konkret mit der angebotenen
literatur und dem bahnangebot des
museumsshops befasst um nur ein paar
details zu nennen die untersuchte
publikums liste umfasst 927 titel die
souvenir liste 639 waren die mit
wissenschaftlichen methoden geprüft und
evaluiert wurden
es wurde ein kriterienkatalog auf basis
des § 3 des verbotsgesetzes das
abzeichen gesetzes und auf basis der
wissenschaftlichen konsens definition
von rechtsextremismus erstellt und da
zeigt es sich wiederum wie unglaublich
wichtig es ist dass man vorwürfen allen
vorwürfen genau nach geht alles genau
und seriös untersucht bzw untersuchen
lässt und nicht unreflektiert
behauptungen folgt denn eines vielleicht
vorweg die vorwürfe über angeblich
politisch rechtsextreme literatur und
waren haben sich als haltlos erwiesen
aber
eines ist auch klar manches ist veraltet
und vieles gibt es zu verbessern und aus
der maus der jetzigen verkauf städte dem
shop einen modernen gut sortierten
museumsshop zu machen
der 2 ansprüche erfüllen muss einerseits
dem bildungsauftrag durch
wissenschaftlich qualitätsvolle
literatur zu erfüllen
die thematisch und inhaltlich auch
ausgewogen ist ja und andererseits zur
erwirtschaftung von einnahmen solcher
bücher beim c block publikum anzubieten
die auch gern gekauft werden
und ich bin daher der kommission herr
professor sehr dankbar das nicht mein
kategorisierung konzept erstellt worden
ist mit fünf kategorien die dem die
untersuchten büchern gegenstände jeweils
zugeordnet wurden sondern es ist darüber
hinaus und was ist besonders
hervorzuheben auch eine liste mit
empfohlener ergänzender literatur
aufgestellt worden
das heißt die kommission hat nicht nur
evaluiert und manchmal kritisiert
sondern sie ist einen schritt weiter
gegangen und hat konstruktive vorschläge
gemacht um das angebot im museumsshop zu
verbessern und zeitgemäß für die
zielgruppe der vielschichtigen
museumsbesucher zu gestalten
sehr geehrte damen und herren wie sieht
nun der weitere weg in die zukunft aus
wir haben nun die berichte der beiden
mutsch kommissionen wir haben den
rechnungshofbericht und wir haben nun
den bericht von herrn universitäts
professor dr müller zum warenangebotes
ag museumsshops vor uns liegen
mit diesen vier berichten ist die
erhebungsphase jetzt abgeschlossen und
wir sind in der internen
schätzungsweise und den
dementsprechenden bearbeitungen
angelangt wir alle wissen die
anforderungen im museumsbereich sind
ohne zweifel gestiegen und sie sind sehr
komplex geworden daher muss das agm
mache stabil aufgestellt werden
es ist notwendig dass wir die
wirtschaftlichen und die
organisatorischen rahmenbedingungen
stärken
wir haben daher im
verteidigungsministerium bereits das
projekt heeresgeschichtlichen museum
militärhistorisches institute einführen
qualitätsmanagementsystem und
controlling stabs element aufgesetzt wir
haben einige bereiche im
qualitätsmanagement bereits fertig
gestellt wir streben zudem einen
ständigen wissenschaftlichen beirat für
das jahres geschichtliche museum an der
die künftige führung des museums auf
wissenschaftlicher ebene beraten soll
und es werden 4,3 millionen euro
zusätzlich zur modernisierung und
digitalisierung der ausstellungen
investiert wir werden außerdem die
führung des museums neu ausschreiben und
wir werden mit der künftigen führung des
museums ein gesamtkonzept erstellen und
durchführen lassen
schritt für schritt sind wir dabei aus
unserem heeresgeschichtlichen museum ein
modernes zeitgemäßes museum zu schaffen
durch den bericht mit den empfehlungen
und insbesondere auch der ergänzenden
literatur liste von herrn professor
müller ist das beim museumsshop sogar
sehr rasch möglich ich darf daher nun
schon das wort an herrn professor müller
übergeben mit einem abschließenden
dankeschön für die umfangreiche arbeit
vielen dank
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin meine
damen und herren
im vorigen jahr wurde nach langen
vorbereitungen eine kommission zur
evaluierung des gesamten warenangebots
im museumsshop des heeresgeschichtlichen
museums wien hgm einberufen bestehend
aus universitäts professoren dr kerstin
von lingen universität wien institut für
zeitgeschichte doktor ich hat gehrmann
anwesend ebenfalls instituts für
zeitgeschichte magister stefan roth
dokumentationsarchiv des
österreichischen widerstandes
universitäts professor dr super
österreichische akademie der
wissenschaften sowie meiner person
auftragsgemäß führte die kommission fünf
sitzungen samt lokalaugenschein durch
lektüre wurde zum teil in heimarbeit
erledigt ich möchte daher meinen
kollegen und meiner kollegin besonders
dr
germana schriftführer großen dank für
die engagierte mitarbeit aussprechen
eben solcher dank gilt auch dem personal
und dem direktor des hg mdr christian
ortner die alle anfragen und
bestellungen punkt und frankreich
erfüllten bzw beantwortet der prüfumfang
wurde durch die aktuellen waren listen
des hgm definiert allfällige früher im
angebot befindlichen waren oder
publikationen wurden nicht begutachtet
von der inhaltlichen begutachtung
ausgenommen wurden ferner erstens
publikationen des bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung gehe insbesondere
auch die umfangreiche truppendienst wir
gehen davon aus dass publikationen des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung einer entsprechend
monatlichen vorab prüfung unterliegen
sollte das nicht der fall sein ist das
denke ich sicherlich auch etwas was man
einrichten kann und soll
zweitens die zeitschrift pallasch die
aus zeitgründen nur stichprobenartig
begutachtet werden konnte sie können
sich vorstellen wenn 40 hälfte einer
zeitschrift mit jeweils 10 bis 20
artikeln da liegen dann übersteigt das
auch
die zeitressourcen einer fünf personen
kommission die eben nicht nur diese 40
hefte sondern insgesamt 900
publikationen in einigen monaten zu
prüfen hat drittens ausgenommen wurde
literatur zu nach 1945 in gebrauch
befindlichen waffensystemen angesichts
der dimension des auftrages auf die
zahlen hat frau bundesministerin bereits
hingewiesen vielen dank dafür und der
vorhandenen ressourcen musste von einer
voll inhaltlichen evaluation der
gesamtheit der verbleibenden
publikationen und waren abstand genommen
werden
es wurden somit anhand von autor autorin
titel verlag und beschreibung eine
vorauswahl getroffen und auf dieser
grundlage eine evaluation der so
ermittelten auswahl durchgeführt auch
die wissenschaftlichen und
rechtsgrundlagen ist ebenfalls von
bundesministerin schon eingegangen
für die inhaltliche evaluierung der
geprüften werke und waren wurden diese
untersucht auf tendenziöse oder
unausgewogene darstellung der
militärgeschichte österreichs vor allem
während der zeit der habsburger
monarchie insbesondere im ersten
weltkrieg der republik beziehungsweise
der ns-zeit glorifizierung des krieges
an sich sowie insbesondere der
kombattanten und bewaffneten formationen
des deutschen reiches und tennis tpc
verharmlosungen oder relativierungen von
kriegsverbrechen oder auch staatlichen
verbrechen insbesondere des ns regimes
oder auch andere totalitäre regime in
dem ein dem demokratie geschichts und
werteverständnis der zweiten republik
nicht entsprechend des traditions-
verständnis insbesondere mit blick auf
die berücksichtigung des widerstandes
gegen den nationalsozialismus die opfer
des krieges generell und des
nationalsozialismus im besonderen
neben diesen inhaltlichen kriterien
versuchte die kommission auch eine
evaluierung der gesamten zusammensetzung
des publikations und warenangebotes
vorzunehmen
dabei wurde das sortiment auf
berücksichtigung der wesentlichen
thematischen aspekte geprüft
zu beachten war dabei insbesondere ob
aufgrund des vorliegenden angebot seine
ausgewogene darstellung zentraler
militär historische ereignisse
strukturen und persönlichkeiten möglich
ist und dabei auch negative aspekte
sowie opfer oder auch minderheiten
perspektiven sowie insbesondere
gegebenenfalls kriegsverbrechen
erwähnung finden
zu den quantitativen und qualitativen
ergebnissen hat die kommission
festgestellt die zusammensetzung des
sortiments ist breit und diverse die
meisten der zu erwartenden bereiche der
militärgeschichte von 1600 bis zur
gegenwart werden abgedeckt positiv
gewertet wurde dass dabei neben standard
überblicks und spezial literatur auch
kritische minderheiten und opfer
perspektiven berücksichtigt sind
ich nenne zum beispiel studien zu
kriegsverbrechen und zum so genannten
schmutzigen krieg der habsburger
monarchie im ersten weltkrieg von hannes
leidinger frauenbildern im krieg
gabriele schaumann karin schmidt oder
schabowski k&k soldaten jüdischer
herkunft eine arbeitskollegin schmiedel
besonders reichhaltig ist das angebot
zum ersten weltkrieg und zum waffen und
uniform wesen das angebot zum zweiten
weltkrieg ist weniger vielfältig es
umfasst kurze aber solide und anerkannte
überblicke zur ns-zeit und zum weltkrieg
insgesamt sowie zum holocaust
beispielsweise zu stalingrad
monographien zum zwanzigsten juli 44 zum
widerstand in österreich ich nenne hier
das standardwerk von wolfgang neugebauer
zum luftkrieg über österreich zur
schlacht um wien und einige arbeiten zu
verschiedenen themen der ns herrschaft
und politik hinzu kommen titel die vor
allem kontext der opfer und
kriegsteilnehmer perspektiven
repräsentieren kriegsverbrechen und
holocaust sind zwar in überblicks werken
thematisiert und mit einigen kapiteln
beziehungsweise monografische
beispielsweise vom dieter pohl
berücksichtigt aber quantitativ etwas
unterrepräsentiert
darauf bezieht sich dann auch die von
der frau bundesministerin bereits
angesprochene empfehlungsliste ich werde
darauf zurückkommen
ein breiteres angebot an literatur zum
sogenannten vernichtungskrieg und zu
kriegsverbrechen wäre wünschenswert und
würde der kritischen militär
geschichtsforschung der vergangenen 25
jahre durchaus rechnung tragen dem
gegenüber steht eine fülle technisch
ausgerichtete literatur zu
waffensystemen letzteres wurde vom
direktor des hgm im kommissions-
gespräch für uns auch durchaus
nachvollziehbar begründet erstens damit
dass es beabsichtigt ist hintergrund
literatur zu den ausgestellten schweren
geräten anzubieten
und zweitens dass infolge der
renovierung der panzerhalle das
sortiment technischer literatur von dort
in den h gameshop transferiert wurde
die kommission empfiehlt daher die
ergänzung von literatur insbesondere zum
zweiten weltkrieg zu kriegsverbrechen
und zum holocaust sowie zum thema
österreicher und österreicherinnen im
zweiten weltkrieg insbesondere in der
wehrmacht aber auch aus alternativen
perspektiven aus opfer frauen und
widerstands perspektiven als impuls
wurde die genannte auswahl liste
empfohlener internationale literatur
übermittelt hier finden sie
beispielsweise werke aus der so
genannten schwarzen reihe s fischer
verlag und ähnlich ist das ist günstiger
anerkannte literatur die sich auch sehr
gut als einstiegs lektüre und auch für
hintergründe eignet die inhaltliche
evaluation ergab folgendes bild
publikationen mit rechtsextremen den
nationalsozialismus glorifizierenden
oder die demokratie gefährden dem inhalt
wurden von der kommission nicht
identifiziert aufgrund von zu wenig
kritischer aber nicht strafrechtlich
relevanter darstellung insbesondere von
akteuren und operationen des zweiten
weltkrieges wird die entfernung von zehn
titeln
das sind 1,3 prozent der geprüften
empfohlen einige aufgelistete werke
lagen nicht mehr vor
unter berücksichtigung der titel
beziehungsweise der verfasser wird
empfohlen sieben werke davon dass ist
circa ein prozent nicht nach zu
bestellen und nicht weiter zu vertreiben
etwa zwölf prozent der geprüften titel
vor allem zum thema heeres organisation
ausrüstung uniformierung und
waffentechnik sind die anlage und
struktur überwiegend facto grafisch und
technisch die folgen und opfer des
einsatzes der dargestellten armeen
operationen oder waffengegner
gegebenenfalls auch kriegsverbrechen etc
sind hier wenn überhaupt im
militärjargon formuliert wenig oder gar
nicht beleuchtet
daher wird empfohlen diese titel zur
waffentechnik auf redundanz und qualität
im detail zu prüfen gegebenenfalls
insgesamt quantitativ auszutarieren
beziehungsweise die technische literatur
wieder in die panzerhalle zu
transferieren
die überwältigende anzahl und das sind
85 prozent der geprüften titel ist nicht
zu beanstanden im gegenteil finden sich
darunter zum teil exzellente überblicks
und spezial werke über hintergründe und
praxis bewaffneter konflikte
insbesondere der weltkriege wobei auch
wie gesagt negative seiten vom soldaten
schicksalen opfer und minderheiten
perspektiven gezeigt werden
es gibt ferner nachschlagewerke und
bildbände und typen kompasse diese
stärken gilt es zu stärken mit dem von
mir bereits angesprochenen inhaltlichen
fokus auch auf den zweiten weltkrieg und
holocaust und die problematik der
kriegsverbrechen
die kommission ist sich des umstandes
bewusst dass die empfehlungen nur nach
maßgabe des buchmarktes und auch
wirtschaftliche erwägungen umgesetzt
werden können
es handelt sich hier um keine
fachbibliothek sondern um einen
buchladen bei fremdsprachiger literatur
sind die entsprechenden wissenschafts
traditionen zu berücksichtigen
all jene von ihnen die sich damit näher
auseinandergesetzt haben ist das auch
gut bekannt dass beispielsweise in der
angelsächsischen tradition hier etwas
weniger sensibel formuliert wird als das
mittlerweile glücklicherweise in der
deutschsprachigen literatur in der
anerkannten deutschsprachigen literatur
der fall ist in diesem sinne ist
abzuwägen welche titel als ein
bildungsangebot geführt werden sollen
und welche nachgefragt werden und welche
auch umsätze erwirtschaften
das entlang beider vektoren nur sachlich
und rechtlich korrekte werke in frage
kommen bedarf keiner näheren erläuterung
nicht erkennen
herzlichen dank ich darf nun ihre fragen
bieten und versuchen zu warten bis das
mikrofon benders bitte das mikrofon
bitte schön kontakt wollte huber lang
von der apa vor ministerin können sie
einen zeithorizont für die weiteren
schritte bisschen skizzieren waren gibt
es denn dieses gesamtkonzept und wann
wird dann endlich die ausschreibung des
neuen direktor postens erfolgen
wie gesagt wir kommen jetzt von der
erhebungsphase in die umsetzungsphase
das eine wird schneller gehen und zwar
der inhalt der heutigen pressekonferenz
die umsetzung der empfehlungen die das
warensortiment und das buch angebote im
shop anbelangt nächste schritte wird im
ressort stattfinden beziehungsweise
findet laufend statt das sind die
umsetzungen der empfehlungen des
rechnungshofberichtes wo wir in der
letzten pressekonferenz ja schon über
den derzeitigen standard informiert
haben oder weitere schritt ist die
einsetzung der kommission dazu gibt
zunächste übernächste woche einen termin
mit dem leiter mit herrn professor
moritz und im anschluss daran sobald
sozusagen die internen vorkehrungen
abgeschlossen sind wird der prozess der
ausschreibt
aufgesetzt die nächste frage war eine
inhaltliche etappe aber haben sie keinen
anhaltspunkt in sie uns geben können
wann wann das in etwa erfolgen kann
sie sprechen jetzt die ausschreibung an
oder oder die die einzelnen schritte
aber wie gesagt die umsetzung dessen
wird schneller gehen wir gehen davon aus
dass im herbst der wir so weit sein
werden dass die schritte für die
ausschreibung fertig sind in der
sulzbacher ja du sollst backer vom
standort ich habe gleich einige fragen
die erste ist habe ich das richtig
verstanden dass überprüfte warenangebot
ist nicht ident nicht ident mit dem
angebot als es diese medienberichte gab
die zweite frage ist wurde auch der shop
in der panzerhalle überprüft also
genauer gesagt dessen angebot und die
dritte frage ist warum wurde nicht das
gesamte angebot überprüft im bericht
steht etwa dass die souvenirs nur
stichprobenartig angeschaut haben also
von einer überprüfung ist der volieren
nicht ergeben
danke vielleicht darf ich ja sogar den
ersten teil der frage in sofia nach
beantworten
es hat ja als die ersten die ersten
äußerungen kamen dass es hier
rechtsextreme umtriebe ich glaube so
wurde das zumindest in der
parlamentarischen anfrage auch genannt
heeresgeschichtlichen museum gebe
seitens meines vorgängers schon erste
schritte gesetzt
das war die befassung insbesondere auch
der zuständigen fachabteilungen in
unserem ressort die diese objektiven
vorwürfe dann diese vorwürfe objektiv zu
prüfen hatten und da mag es schon sein
dass in der vergangenheit der eine oder
andere schritt gesetzt worden ist
in meiner amtszeit war es mir wichtig
dass eine nicht nur die fachabteilungen
des eigenen hauses sondern dass eine
kommission
sich damit eben befasst und der auftrag
dieser kommission konnte daher nur sein
das was vorzufinden ist auch zu
überprüfen das so weit von meiner seite
aber der herr professor können das sich
hinter teil ja was die erste frage
betrifft
die kommission konnte natürlich nur das
ansehen was hier zugänglich gemacht
wurde und das was letzten endes auch
dann vorhanden gewesen ist unsere daten
grundlage war die im kommissionsbericht
genannte auflistung wie sie uns vom
heeresgeschichtlichen museum zur
verfügung gestellt worden ist kann
konkret eine auflistung für die bücher
eine seite für die souvenirs damit
konnten wir operieren wir konnten nicht
operieren oder einfach aus zeitgründen
und auch aus unseren auftrag betrifft
mit medienberichten das hätte eine
medien recherche über die vergangenen
zwei jahre wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere ist dass aus 2009 10 sind diese
berichte gewesen einerseits hätte das
eben einen sehr großen umfang
dargestellt der nicht in unserem auftrag
enthalten gewesen ist zum anderen sind
ja wenn ich korrekt informiert bin und
die dinge sind ja auch über das
parlament entsprechend publiziert worden
die konkreten vorwürfe 20 19 gegenstand
von anfragebeantwortungen im
österreichischen nationalrat gewesen an
den damaligen bundesminister für
landesverteidigung und es ist somit von
uns nicht weiter überprüft worden auch
aufgrund eben des prüfauftrag ist was
die panzerhalle betrifft so ist derzeit
dort wie wir uns im zuge des
lokalaugenscheins überzeugen konnten
überhaupt keinen buchladen vorhanden die
panzerhalle wird renoviert
sie ist führungs insoferne daneben teil
der des kommissions- gesprächs mit dem
direktor des geschichtlichen museums
auch gewesen als
mehr uns gesagt hat dass eben dieser
doch recht starke technische anteil der
literatur
daraus resultiert dass eben die
literatur aus der panzerhalle jetzt in
das hauptgebäude transferiert wurde das
war für uns relevant und soweit ich
informiert bin soll auch dort wiederum
nach der eröffnung wenn es kein bisher
ein neues konzept insgesamt für das für
die panzer alle gibt wiederum ein buch
verkauf stattfinden was die dritte frage
nämlich die nach stichproben der
souvenirs betrifft so muss ich
einerseits wiederum auf den recht großen
umfang hinweisen wir haben sie eben mit
über 600 einzel gegenständen zu tun
die natürlich im vergleich zu der
literatur wesentlich weniger prüfaufwand
zeitlich bedürfen buch muss man lesen
oder zumindest einmal durchblättern und
die entsprechenden signifikanten kapitel
an steuern ein souvenir das reicht wenn
man es wenn man kurz in der hand gehabt
hat oder aber eben eine liste hat und
auf dieser liste ist eine beschreibung
drauf wir sind daher ähnlich vorgegangen
auch wie bei den büchern und haben
zuerst einmal eine vorauswahl getroffen
was müssen wir uns überhaupt anschauen
und das sind dann eben auch die dinge
gewesen die wir stichprobenartig
überprüft haben ich habe jetzt gerade
die liste hier vor mir nicht geöffnet
wenn ich da nur kurz illustrativ einige
dinge heraus greifen darf wir haben hier
einen
einen ein abzeichen er total wir haben
eine replik des ordens signum lautes
kann der erste erster weltkrieg
wir haben ein cockpit schloss diverse
ausführungen wir haben einen account
karl bremen wir haben dvds portisch
österreich 2 wir haben
ritter modell und ähnliches mehr als
aufgebraucht dann nicht in details gehen
dass man dass wir bei fünf sitzungen uns
mit solchen dingen dann nicht im detail
beschäftigen können ich glaube das
versteht sich um dies auch durch ist
durchaus legitim
gibt es weitere fragen wenn es keine
weitere fragen gibt dann sage ich
herzlichen dank für kommen und beendete
pressekonferenz